[Musica]
la sorella morta se ne va se io rimasi
chiarissimo netflix e netflix perfetto
non posso fare né freddo oggi si lavora
e basta a cazzeggiare su netflix farisei
fi registra i video che sono sti poveri
cristiani non c'hanno video di giornata
fra i video
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fuori j e oggi siamo sul mio
ipad
l'altro giorno mi sono messo a cercare
dei giochi sull'app store per vedere se
c'era qualcosa di carino che che era
uscito e ho trovato le la roba super
intelligente come ad esempio corri
salsiccia corri cominciamo non
chiedetevi che cosa diavolo non è il
verme quello di io sono stata zitta e
tutto ciò che devo fare è togliere la
pubblicità 18 mi dà fastidio a devo
schivare gli ostacoli beccarino sono
proprio bravo sono schierato in si
giochi va beh sono fatemi capire un
attimo porte st musichetta da ebeti
continue ho sbagliato ho sbagliato porca
vacca le pubblicità schifosa maledetto
che monetizza 24 secondi di baio vi
ammazzo i parenti ricapitolando ragazzo
non sta salsiccia e tutto ciò che devo
fare è correre più veloce inchinarmi per
schivare gli ostacoli
c'è una roba il premio nobel ha creato
sto gioco ok perfetto va tutto già
record faccio veramente pena però non ne
frega una sega degli scimpanzé gesù tap
to run
già è difficile sto gioco per cortese è
possibile che faccio così cagare niente
non riesco a fare un metro ricapitolando
la gara un gioco dove sono una salsiccia
però ok però tutto ciò che devo fare è
cliccare su schermo per andare più
veloce piegarmi per evitare gli ostacoli
per un gioco premio nobel chi
ma io come faccio a passare i forni è
impossibile tua madre fa le cose proprio
bene perché questa pubblicità simulator
ragazzi
adesso faccio questo video di 10 minuti
mette una pubblicità seconda zitti pure
anche difficile come il problema best 34
niente non riesco a fare un mezzo sul
quale è l'apoteosi del nulla
gesù ok c'è veramente un genio che aveva
questo gioco e proprio anni anni di
evoluzione dell'essere umano per questo
raga mi sembra che i film d'animazione
che avevo visto sulle salsicce che
parlano tipo una roba del genere
comunque 50 punti raga e così che
rimorchio con la salsiccia frase no
questa cosa a sono tutti ok sono tutti
frizzati finissimo porca vacca per 80
non è male non è male possiamo goderci
le mezz'ora di pubblicità adesso no
matter 80 per ragazzi l'obiettivo di
stupido sarà arrivare a centrare il meno
a 100 sono convinto di riuscirci non
sono più tanto convinto adesso c'è il
vicino raga non so big potato free for
three rams va bene bene l'ho già guarda
quanto misurerà ragazzi secondo voi da
uno a zero secondi zero secondi porca di
una punta solo questo è di di ipad non
posso neanche niente mi è durato 3 con
comunque ragazzi non è così semplice
come sembra perché vi giuro che è
veramente un casino ti devi fermare per
forza ogni torto perché sono farina
finaccia incredibile però tutto ria se
vado più piano
forse a 100 c arrivo forse è per carità
c'è poi sono curioso di sapere l'agente
che cos'è sta roba aiuto cos'è successo
cosa vuol dire showroom non so l'inglese
l'aiuto ok frase queste cose porca vacca
cielo quasi 77 80 ragazzi record
perfetto bisogni no non è vero
certo ce l'ho fatta va bene va bene 107
sticazzi comunque ragazzi hanno detto
che c'è un appendino ha perso a ci sono
personaggi diversi capisco possa essere
un dito con tanto di anello tra l'altro
va bene va bene cup capisco il gioco
serio c'è veramente call of duty
spostati al giorno invece che cercare il
suo aborto sull'app store non potevo
fare tipo qualsiasi altra cosa ma perché
renta non ha senso di esistere il suo
gioco
no bene così perfetto ok dover battere
107 che va beh non so che cosa fatta
arrivare a 100 sono anche uno fatta
arriva la scelta come farci arrivare 107
me lo dite voi certamente non ne ho idea
raga
ok detto ok va bene così sta roba
avevo lo scudo che ho perso subito tipo
niente lo scudo durato meno del secolo
ero fermo qua non ho neanche corso sono
morto perché c'è la madre che fa le
sedie però non ero fermo io e ora gas
senza ancora tre secondi dista
canzoncina vi giuro muoio per narnia
perfetto o lo scudo raga ma io dopo devo
guardarmi in video di qualcuno che fa il
record su sta roba perché vuoi vedere
che disagio c'è nel nel mondo
porca vacca cosa è tua zia morta ieri
niente c'è poi ragazzi la gente mi
scrive ma soprattutto litro visti i
giochi schifo minchia veramente solo io
li trovo stilistica gatte umane
il ninja lo trovo sbloccato il ninja
ragala vi pare ma va bene un po a
salerno il violetto di così non va
cioè non ha veramente senso che io mi
incazzo per una salsiccia ci stiamo
paolina salsiccia una salsiccia ninja
rega ma dico stiamo parlando vediamo di
non perderlo in 3 secondi e grazie molto
gentili ciao finta di non averlo
facciamo finta di non averlo proprio che
allarga non potevo fare niente altro che
prenderlo occhio
bene io non ho lo scudo io non lo scudo
virano lo scudo io lo scudo non cielo
non ce l'ho addosso devo proseguire
senza come se fossero i core normale
vedi che ci vada sera sarà la madonna ci
va addosso da sarah
[Musica]
ma do mato rega sta nevicando talmente
impossibile sta nevicando che è successo
è cambiata la schermata aiuto c'è più
niente
ho pagato il gioco record mondiale ho
pagato giovani soffio star sarebbe stato
troppo bello quindi sono in sintesi per
dare una chiusura sono contentissimo di
aver cercato ieri i giochi sull'app
store ma io ho fatto scelta migliore
nella mia vita
però devo dire che almeno il concept
divertente se non fosse che è frustrante
da schifo e poi ci sono degli ostacoli
che le volte non puoi proprio schivare
mori a prescindere va a culo potenziare
perfetto e no ma non c'erano gli
ostacoli qua prima non mi fai fare tipo
mezzo chilometro vuoto va bene ha
spiegato raga è stato divertente giuro
mi è piaciuta tantissimo stasera
sicuramente ci giocherò di nuovo ci
giocherò dimostra sera ne sono
pienamente convinto ragazzi miei spero
che video vi sia piaciuto non il gioco
il video cose i ragazzi se video
piaciuto mi piace anche ai socialisti
trascrizione ricordatevi che è
importante è usare la salsiccia e poi
sembra che dico cosa ambigua chiediamo
questo video prima che scenda troppo nel
trash
beh ragazzi
[Musica]